good morning happy Monday all devices
off by the way to my far right dr. Jim
Alaris to my immediate right real doctor
took her to my left
Melissa DeRozan secretary to governor to
her left
Robert mihika the budget director calls
himself doctor of the budget it's not a
real doctor today is 51 days since the
first case in New York just for
perspective so we know where we are 92
days since the first case came to the
United States of America I was in
Seattle and in California these are the
hospitalization numbers for today tick
down from yesterday but a slight tick
statistically irrelevant the question
for us is we are we past the apex we
have had a number of days that have seen
a reduction and reductions of course the
board hospitals also say anecdotally
that they have less patients in their
emergency room which again perspective
the emergency rooms were way over
capacity it was chaotic it was hellish
and the emergency rooms are still at or
over capacity but it's better than it
was the total change in hospitalizations
you see that it's been going down the 3
d average of hospitalizations is going
down number of intubations is down again
that is great news
not down as much as yesterday but down
number of new people coming in the door
with COFA diagnosis is again just about
flat with yesterday this was reporting
over a weekend sometimes the weekend
reporting can get a little funky because
it's Saturday and Sunday and they have
less of a staff the reporting may not be
as accurate but it's pay
silly flat the question that we
initially dealt with at the beginning of
this as the numbers were going up the
question was how long until we reach the
top of the mountain right every day was
the numbers higher the numbers higher
than I was higher than the numbers
higher question was when do you get to
the top how high can it go then we get
to the top at the top turns out not to
be a peak it turns out to be a plateau
and then we're on the plateau and it's
basically flat and then the question was
how long are we gonna be on this plateau
how long how wide is the plateau the
question now is assuming we're off the
plateau and we're seeing a descent which
the numbers would suggest we're seeing a
descent the question is now how long is
the descent and how steep is the descent
and nobody knows just the way nobody
knew how long the ascent was nobody can
tell you how long the descent is and
that's what we're trying to figure out
the numbers coming down but how fast
does the number come down and how fast
does the number come down to where it
becomes a low enough number that we have
some confidence that we have a margin of
error does it take two weeks for it to
come down some projections say that does
it take a month some projections say
that and again the projections are nice
but I wouldn't bet the farm on them and
I don't even have a farm worst news is
the number of lives lost that number is
still horrifically high if you're
looking for the optimists view it's not
as bad as it was but 478 New Yorkers
died yesterday from this terrible virus
everyone is anxious to reopen everyone
is anxious to get back to work so a my
question is what does that mean how do
we do it when do we do it nobody
disagree
is that we want to get out of this
situation nobody
you don't need protests to convince
anyone in this country that we have to
get back to work and we have to get the
economy going and we have to get out of
our homes nobody the question is going
to become how when how fast and what do
we mean in terms of reopening with
reopening I want to set the bar higher
meaning the question shouldn't be
when do we reopen and what do we reopen
the question should be let's use this
situation this crisis this time to
actually learn the lessons value from
the reflection and let's reimagine what
we want society to be and since we are
going to have to go through all of this
and it's not going to be fast let's at
least make this a moment that when we
look back we can say wow we went through
hell but look at all the lessons we
learned and look at how much better we
made this place from this incident right
we went through 9/11 were hellish what
we had to rebuild yeah but we were smart
enough to say how do we build back
better you look at downtown Manhattan
now it is better than it was before 9/11
you look at the security procedures that
this nation has we're better than we
were before 9/11 we had superstorm sandy
here on Long Island
terrible terrible thousands of people's
homes gone Long Island is better today
for having gone through superstorm sandy
okay how do we use this situation and
you stop saying reopen but reimagine and
improve and build back better and you
can ask this question on any level how
do we have a better transportation
system a better housing system better
public safety system better health
system better better social equity
better use of technology
who are working from home a lot of them
are saying you know what I should have
been doing this all along
you have telemedicine that we've been
very slow on why was everybody going to
a doctor's office all that time why
didn't you do it using technology why
haven't we been using more technology
for education why haven't we
incorporated so many of these lessons
well because change is hard and people
are slow now is the time to do it and
that's what we're doing in a multi-state
regional coalition and that's very
important because that is the smartest
way to do it on a more granular level
here in New York we're gonna have a
reimagine task force that focuses
primarily on downstate New York which
has been the most effective area and led
by the state with those local elected
officials but let's get the best housing
experts let's get the best
transportation as experts and let's use
this as a moment to really plan change
that we could normally never do unless
you had this situation in the meantime
do no harm and this is my number one
concern every day do no harm
don't let that infection rate go up and
that's testing and that is watching the
dial right we know what's going to
happen now the weather is going to warm
people are a little more relaxed because
they see the numbers coming down and we
know human behavior right they want to
get out of the house they want to be
more active and there's a sanity
quotient to this whole situation there's
only so long you can say to people stay
in the house and lock the door right
they have to go out and do something and
they will they will come out with a
warmer weather and we do have parks and
there are recreation areas it's not even
healthy to stay in the house all the
time but that is going to happen that
activity level is going to increase
naturally
when that activity level increases you
can very well see that infection rate
spread infection rate is primarily a
function of contact you touch a surface
and then I touch a service you cough and
the droplets go on me its contact and
that's why places like New York City or
anywhere you see a hotspot cluster New
Rochelle it was about contact people
start coming out they start moving
around more
there will be more contact that contact
will increase the virus spread watch the
dial watch the virus contract contact
spread you'll see it in the
hospitalization rate to the extent we're
doing testing you'll see it in the
testing rate but remember how thin our
margin of error we work 1.2 1.3 1.4
that's when the virus is outbreak one
person is infecting more than one
additional person when you get the the
infection rate below one theoretically
the virus is slowing we're at 0.9 we
have point 9 to 1.2 that is a very fine
margin of error I don't even know that
it's statistically relevant frankly
because all of these numbers are a
little loose but that's what we have to
watch and we will when we have to watch
this until we have a medical treatment
or we have a vaccine that's when this is
really over in the meantime I say again
to my local government officials I'm
getting a lot of calls from a lot of
Supervisors
elected officials etc they're under
increasing political pressure and
they're wanting to do things the state
rule is now everything is closed and the
state rule is they can't take in the
action that is contrary to that because
coordination and discipline is now key
beaches public facilities schools
parades concerts these would all be
magnets for people I work with our other
states because frankly if they open up a
beach in Connecticut you could see a
flow of people from New York going to a
beach in Connecticut if I don't open our
beaches or if they have a concert in New
Jersey people are cooped up here you
could see them get in a car and drive to
New Jersey to a concert by the way is to
drive to New Jersey
the concerts anyway without Kofi I told
someone yesterday I ran into a couple in
Albany who said we're from Queens
they're in a car eating out of styrofoam
trays they drove up from Queens to buy
Thai food and Albany takeout because
they like the Thai food restaurant in
Albany I said you drove from Queens to
Albany to buy Thai food two-and-a-half
hours three hours I see you know they
have Thai restaurants in Queens all due
respect to the Thai restaurants in
Albany they're very very good but would
you really drive three hours they said
we just had to get out of the house we
got to do something so we like to take a
drive so anything that Jersey
Connecticut New York does can affect
everyone else Suffolk does something
Westchester does something New York City
does something it affects everyone else
that is the reality so everything is
closed unless we say otherwise and the
most important thing I just had this
conversation with a local official look
people need government to work
government has to be smart
and if it looks confused between the
state and the county or the state in the
town that's the wrong message for
everyone so let's just be smart on
testing and funding those are the two
areas that we're looking to work with
our federal partners testing is going to
[ __ ] the world is going to require
everyone to work together federal and
state state and locals by the way we're
starting the largest antibody test ever
done today in New York the largest
sample but this has to be a multi-level
government coordinate of project because
we have to do this on an ongoing basis
also on the funding issue this is
obviously a unique period in a lot of
ways we did a state budget in a way
we've never done it before
since our state didn't have any revenues
the way we did the budget was we
basically said it's dependent on what we
get from the federal government and the
federal government that promised funding
all along we said whatever we get from
the federal government will determine
our state budget right because the state
has a 15 10 to 15 billion dollar hole
right now and that's never been done
before it basically said I'll tell you
the state budget when I know the state
budget and the state budget is going to
be a function of whatever the federal
government gives us the federal
government has not funded States to date
the National Governors Association
bipartisan headed by a chairman governor
Hogan Republican I'm the vice chairman
we have said with one voice you want the
governor's to do the job we need to
provide funding for state governments
there's now another piece of legislation
they're talking about passing in
Washington
again it doesn't have state and local
governments in it but if this week we're
going to do a state forecast if they
exclude state government again our state
forecast will project without any
federal funds you can't spend what you
don't have if you were to do allocate
this shortfall relatively on a flat
basis across need you would be cutting
schools 20% local governments 20% in
hospitals 20% and this is the worst time
to do this now federal government is
said from day one don't worry we're
going to provide funding to the states
yeah don't worry but I'm worried because
I've heard this over and over again and
my job is very simple I have one agenda
I've one up one purpose I fight for New
Yorkers that is my job I don't have any
side jobs I don't have any other places
to go people to see that's all I do and
I'm telling you New Yorkers need funding
for this budget because we can't do it
otherwise and look Washington is saying
what we want to fund small business yeah
great
you should fund small businesses and
they want to fund financial services and
large corporations and airlines and
hotels yeah that's all great fund all
those businesses but at the same time
don't forget teachers and police
officers and firefighters and transit
workers and health care workers a
nursing home staff because those are the
people who I fund with the state budget
and you shouldn't make us choose between
small businesses and large businesses
and people who are on the front line
doing the work day in and day out I
would even go a step further and I would
propose hazard pay
for frontline workers we all say boy
they did a great job the health care
workers did a great job the police the
heroes yes they are but you know what
thanks is nice but also recognition of
their efforts and their sacrifice is
also appropriate they are the ones that
are carrying us through this crisis and
this crisis is not over
and if you look at who they are and the
equity and fairness of what has happened
I think any reasonable person would say
we should right this wrong 40% of the
frontline workers are people of color
45% in public transit 57% of the
building workers 40% of the health care
workers people of color also
disproportionately represented the
represented in delivery services and
childcare services right the economy
closed down the economy did not close
down it closed down for those people who
frankly have the luxury of staying at
home all those essential workers who had
to get up every morning to put food on
the shelves and go to the hospitals to
provide health care under extraordinary
circumstances in the police officer who
had to go out to keep you safe and the
firefighter who still had to go out and
and fight the fire those people worked
and they went out there and they exposed
themselves to the virus two-thirds of
those frontline workers are women
one-third come from low-income
households so they've been doing this
work they've been stressed they're going
home to a household often had to wage
earners one of them is not now not
working that they're living just on that
one salary and after all of that we see
the infection rate among
african-american and brown Americans
higher proportionately than other groups
why because they were out there exposing
themselves that's why
can talk about health despairities etc
but I believe all the studies gonna wind
up saying yes when you were home with
your doors locked
dealing with cabin fever they were out
there dealing with the corona virus and
that's why they are more infected pay
them what they deserve I would say
hazard pay give them a 50% bonus and I
would do that now yes airlines also
frontline workers also we have a need
and a responsibility to get the
assistance we need to people in
low-income communities we have Naija is
public housing in the city of New York
high concentration of people in one
place many people in the small lobby
many people in elevator many people in
hallways a higher number of people in
the apartment just a higher occupancy
that's where the virus spreads we're
going to set up a test program in NYCHA
where we're going to have on-site health
services and testing in the New York
City area with New York City Housing
Authority projects working with local
officials well we're doing it as a pilot
program to see how it works if it works
well we'll go further with it we have as
you see congressman Meeks congressman
and Keene Jeffries Attorney General
Leticia James Speaker Carl Heastie and
Bronx borough president Ruben Diaz who
will be working on this and coordinating
it and I thank them very much we're also
going to bring 500,000 cloth masks to
NYCHA that is one mask for every person
who is in public housing and hand
sanitizer etc just so they have the
necessary equipment they need to do the
social distancing and protection
personal opinion not
fact throw it in the pail what we're
doing here you know as a general rule
what we do determines our future right
as smart as government is as smart as
people are that's how how you shape your
future but this is cause and effect on
steroids what we do today will determine
tomorrow and we're not going to need to
wait to read the history books we make
smart decisions you will see smart
outcomes in two weeks we make bad
decisions you will see bad outcomes in
two weeks so when they say the future is
in our hands the future is really in our
hands and we're going to get through
this we can control the Beast the Beast
will not destroy us we can control the
Beast great news we have a lot of work
to do to keep the beast under control
and we have a lot of work to do to
reopen but we're going to set the bar
high and we're going to reimagine and
what we reopen will be better than what
we had before build back better build
back better VBB and that's what we're
going to do because we are New York
tough and tough isn't just tough tough
is smart toughest disciplines smartest
United and smart is loving questions
James get me we updated our survey this
past week and we're setting to get that
data in and as soon as that's ready
we'll post it just tweeted that the
testing is up to the States not up to
the federal government just a quick
reaction on that and also is the state
capable of doing the type of testing it
needs to be doing in order to not only
identify who has the disease but
as had the disease the president is
right
the state's testing is up to the states
which will implement the tests and
logistically coordinate the tests for
example in this state I should make the
determinations as to what labs
participate in testing we have about 300
labs in New York it's my job to
coordinate those 300 labs which ones to
do this which one should not how do I
decide what labs work where they're
regulated by the states these labs so
how many labs do I have worked in
Suffolk how many lives where I have
working this now so how many labs do I
have work in Buffalo how many tests can
I get done in total how do i allocate
those tests
how many antibody tests different type
of tests antibody tests can I get from
those labs how do I allocate the
antibody tests that's all within the
state purview so I think the president
is right when he says the states should
lead and that's that's the state's
leading what the states will run into is
when you talk to those labs the 300 labs
they buy machines and equipment from
national manufacturers and those labs
can only run as many tests as the
national manufacturers provide them
chemicals reagents and lab kits the
national manufacturers say they have
supply chain issues I'd like the federal
government to help on those supply chain
issues no it's harder than fronting this
is a quagmire because it's not just
funding because I've offered funding to
the national manufacturers and I've said
you know I'll buy I'll pay what do I
have to pay to get the tests the
national manufacturers will
well it's not that easy I can't get the
chemicals the chemicals from to come
from China I can't make the vials fast
enough I can't make the swabs fast
enough so I don't know what's right or
what's wrong with that national supply
chain question but that's where the
federal government could help but should
the states take the lead on the tests
yes
that's exactly right but we need the
volume and the volume is going to be
determined by how well those national
manufacturers provide the kits to the
300 labs in New York once you take the
test there's all second function that
we're not talking about which is you
take the test tracing you know we have
to talk through tracing because people
don't understand what tracing is tracing
is then this function that we've never
done before where you hire an army of
people thousands of people to be
investigators in essence not a scary
investigator but an investigator who
traces the contacts of every person who
is positive that's an entire undertaking
that no one has even imagined before
would you like the federal government to
use they the defense production act to
ramp up production of say supplies and
things like that and then also have the
federal government hire this army of
tracers the tracers I think I would
argue and just my personal opinion as a
governor of New York I would do the
tracing as a state responsibility also
some people think the federal government
should help on tracers I would say the
state can do the tracing and I'll
coordinate buffalo tracers Rochester
tracers Westchester New York City
tracers Nassau Suffolk I think that's
too discreet in action for the federal
government right anything that is
granular and specific to the specific
details of a state leave that to the
state
right you're in the federal government I
used to be in the federal government
federal government you're painting a
room with a roller okay you can't do
corners with a roller you can't do trim
and molding with a roller somebody has
to come behind you with a brush and do
the details state government has a brush
so federal government has a roller I
have a brush let the federal government
do what they can if it requires a brush
let the state government do it the the
big question on the testing is that
national manufacturers supply chain and
getting that up to scale quickly I'll
handle my 300 labs but my 300 labs are
now saying I can't get the tests from
the national manufacturer and the way
this happened because nobody designed
this before and there's nobody's fault
you know right away everybody wants to
go to a host of blame nobody is to blame
the way the testing world worked was a
national manufacturer made their machine
the Andrew Cuomo testing machine I sold
my machine to private labs and hospitals
my machine only operates if you have an
Andrew Cuomo testing kit it doesn't work
with the Howard's our testing testing
kit you have to buy from a and now
what's happening is you call up and say
okay I want to buy a thousand kits I say
you normally only buy a hundred I know
but now I want a thousand I can't get
you a thousand so even though you have
the machine I am so as a national
manufacturer I have such an increased
demand I literally can't produce it in
time and to unravel that supply chain
issue and manufacturing issue I think
that's the best way the federal
government can help good you're
following confused because are you
asking the feds to step in and tell
manufacturers or bring in different
manufacturers to make this sort of
and then you're also asking for the
federal government to pay for the
tracers but you'll handle the kind of
nuts and bolts we didn't get into
payment of tracers I don't think there's
been any proposal where the feds pay do
they I trace no no one's even talking
about pain the states right now pay for
the tests and pay for the tracers that's
why I say when when they say the state's
governor's go reopen okay I'll do the
tests by the way I pay for the tests I
pay for the tracers so it's not about
the money on this front
it's about division of labor and
responsibilities and on the testing I
can't solve for the national
manufacturers not being able to produce
the volume to sell to my state Labs on
Friday we saw a division between those
that are nursing home residents for the
passed away both in the home but then
also in the nursing home set is and also
in the hospital's but what is the
state's policy regarding admission or
readmission to these nursing homes
whether or not one of these people have
tested for the virus or the there was a
state directive that said that people
cannot be denied readmission or
admission just wondering what the state
policy is right now again judging the
high number of deaths that are coming
out if you are tested positive for the
virus are you allowed to be admitted to
a nursing home this question or
readmitted yeah it's a good question I
don't know the policy is that if you are
positive you should be admitted back to
a nursing home the necessary precautions
will be taken to protect the other
residents there is that safe though and
do the staff have the capacity to treat
those individual
at the best place again judging how
rapidly the virus spreads and also this
is a very vulnerable population as you
guys have expressed multiple times and
that's why we're working closely with
the nursing home about the leadership
and the individuals were working in the
nursing home to protect those
individuals who are coming back who had
Cova 19 and were brought back to the
nursing home from where they do well
it's all the issues of supplies PPE
staffing testing of other individuals as
I mentioned the other day just
monitoring to be sure that the necessary
precautions are being taken the
hospitals those tests have been done by
hospitals in New York I think we had
like 20 how many hospitals over 20
hospitals were administering
hydroxychloroquine and doing a test they
are today those hospitals are to send
their results to the FDA down to the FDA
and FDA and CDC and they should be
sending the first tranche of results
today Department of Health gets a copy
but they it's really a study that's
being done for the federal government so
goes to the FDA and CDC yes against a
regional approach but due to so many up
state hospitals laying off people right
now do you think there is a way to bring
back elective surgeries at least for
upstate hospitals and with so many
there's different projections going on
right now and you spoke earlier about a
rolling wave but there are some
projections saying like Erie County for
example they're not necessarily getting
better and they're projected to hit I
think late June you are you worried at
all about rolling projection if there
were to be a regional approach to
reopening yeah two questions both good
ones is there a rolling courage yeah
it's a notion I see a notion they're
rolling curves New York City had the
first curve and then they project higher
curves in other states and other parts
of our state right so Massachusetts is
now coming
to a high point and we're working with
them anything they need we're with them
god bless Buffalo will have a later
curve Albany will have a later curve and
we're watching those curves in different
parts of the state and our strategy has
always been we deploy to wherever the
curve is highest right Massachusetts has
a problem we run to Massachusetts
Buffalo has a problem we run to Buffalo
we run to Rochester so whenever you get
up towards that point and the locality
we're working with to prepare for that
high point second question on the
elective surgeries we stopped elective
surgeries for all hospitals in the state
that was one of the ways we increased
capacity right now we're at a point
where some of the Upstate hospitals have
significant financial burdens because
they're not doing the elective surgery
which is one of the places where they
make money frankly and they're saying
can't we we have lower vacancy we don't
need those beds for New York City people
or Buffalo people or anyone else why not
let us start going back to elective
surgery if we don't need the capacity
that is a good question and we're going
to look at that we are have been looking
at that it's again a little question of
balance and the valve and the dial you
let them go to elective surgery they
fill up the beds with elective surgery
then what happens if you have a need for
those beds because of the coronavirus
and you don't have the bed because
someone is doing some form of elective
surgery that's the balance that we're
going to announce tomorrow a policy that
we believe provides for that and has
some variables that take the coronavirus
rate in that region
and compares it to the vacancy rate in
that region and a potential for a high
point in that region and we'll announce
that tomorrow so yeah Alyssa she has all
the answers coolest are only questions
they've made a significant dent in that
they brought on over 3,100 people to
work daily for the last four days they
brought that 275 thousand applications
down to just over 4300 that are now
outstanding so that's all been cleared
those phone calls all happen those
applications are closed now those
applications get inputted and the
comptroller starts to process the checks
so that backlog of people this week
should see the money coming about 78% of
people choose to get their money through
direct deposit that happens within 48
hours of when the claim is finally
processed which again is happening this
week the applications and the phone
calls getting done was one piece of that
this is now the second piece of it and
then others choose to get their money on
debit card that's a longer process that
takes about a week to come in the mail
so if you can I would encourage people
to go the direct deposit route and the
Department of Labor announced this
morning there was this incredibly
inefficient frankly stupid process that
the federal government laid out around
pandemic unemployment insurance where if
you were a gig worker if you are
self-employed if you're a contractor you
had to apply for unemployment insurance
get denied and then go through the
process a second process of employing
for pandemic unemployment insurance and
what the Department of Labor came up
with was a new form that was launched
this morning where you can now fill out
one application put in all of the
information and the Department of Labor
determines if you are not able to get
regular unemployment insurance it will
automatically put you into the pandemic
unemployment insurance so you don't have
to wait get rejected reapply so that
should hopefully streamline for those
people who I know have been really
struggling to get their money faster
million last week has that increased it
has but we release those numbers weekly
in accordance with the federal
guidelines so I can't speak to that
publicly till the end of the week let's
do someone who do someone who didn't ask
a question research disparity when do we
expect to see some of that research come
to light and politics you know today
regarding testing there that'll take a
while that is a smart academic project
that has a question here that's
developed to get the right demographic
data you're doing diagnostic testing
which is good but with a question here
survey data to get the right
demographics and then you have to study
that that is not going to be done in
time for any of these immediate policies
what we're doing in public housing in
New York City is just common sense you
look at the numbers you know that the
virus attacks in places of concentration
right which is why we have this issue in
New York City in the first place where
the places of concentration in New York
City public housing is one of the
greatest places of concentration and
it's one of the greatest places of
health disparities in the first place
and we know the people in public housing
often don't have the resources to do a
lot of these accommodations themselves
so they've always been the most
vulnerable populations you look at
almost any emergency that happens in the
nation people in public housing always
pay the highest price it seems when I
was HUD secretary one of the things HUD
did was public housing across the
country I don't care if it was a flood
in the Midwest hurricane in
an earthquake in Los Angeles Hurricane
Katrina the people on the top of those
buildings at Hurricane Katrina and in
the stadium those were people from
public house that's we're doing
everything we can as my proposed on
hazard pay focusing on public housing
food banks additional testing doing
everything we can
let's try homeless let's do who didn't
then ask a question you asked me last
week and it's the same answer that I
gave you last week you need testing to
do that we don't have enough testing
where you can break out the sample to a
county level right when you take a we're
taking the most aggressive survey in the
nation right now so we'll have let's say
2,000 people statewide with 2,000 people
you can break down that sample a number
of ways you can look at sex male/female
you can look at demographics
african-american but you can't break it
down to 62 counties because the sample
size would be so small that it
statistically would not be
representative so you would need a
tremendous sample size to be able to get
it down to the county level and well why
don't you do more tests yeah you know we
come right back to we were started we
have to get testing up the scale and
that's this ongoing conversation with
the states in the federal government and
let's
let's just not interrupt each other from
Ken and let people who didn't ask a
question is of course so with all the
issues surrounding testing is it
possible for you to come like are you
even do you even have a threshold of how
many people you would want to see tested
in each county do you have a county note
and but also policies are not gonna
really work on just the county level
you're not going you'll never open
businesses in just the county because
all you would do is overwhelm that
county with everyone in the surrounding
area I think the most discreet
jurisdiction you would get to is a
region like think the regional economic
development council regions western New
York is a region right the North Country
is a region that is an area where you
could come up with a specific strategy
because you know the numbers in that
region and it's just different than it
is anywhere else and we can get in
testing information by region and the
more tests we get done in what they call
the sample size then when you break it
down into demographics
you'll have a higher number in that area
right so if you only have ten people in
the North Country
you can't do anything with ten people in
the sample well if you had 50 people in
the North Country in the sample can you
tell anything from 50 people so you need
a larger sample size and that's what
we're working towards more testing you
mentioned that you mentioned people have
been coming upstate from other areas
people are supposed to be staying
do you need to take further action to
prevent people from traveling to get
food when we're in the middle of a
pandemic that's the left that's the
exact opposite of what you suggested I
do last week which is I was being too
tough on keeping people keeping people
home look it's a balance and and a
certain amount of this is personal
responsibility and civic responsibility
and social conscience frankly and I have
been probably the most aggressive
governor in the country on putting in
regulations and precautions I think I
was justified because we had a worse
problem than anywhere else and we had
that concentration density to deal with
in other issues but I think where we now
we are now is right
I can't mandate personal behavior I
never could my strategy from day one
knowing that we were going to have to
ask people to do things that no
government has asked them to do maybe
since you know World War one or World
War two that the only way I would
actually get compliance because I can
sit up here and say whatever I want to
say and then New Yorkers are very good
at saying you know fine but I'm not
gonna do it the excuse me a second my
strategy has been give them the facts
tell them why why it's in their best
interest why it's in all of our best
interests and they New Yorkers are smart
if they understand why they'll do it and
they have done it by and large you're
right last week some people are not
happy about masks some people are not
happy about staying home but nobody's
happy about any of this so it was never
are you happy I think they've gotten
enough facts where they know we're
talking about their personal health by
the way it's not even the question of
health it's a question of life and death
you're irresponsible here you're
reckless here you could die or you could
get infected come home
kiss your mother and your mother dies I
mean that's what we're talking about so
I think they got it I don't think
there's anything more I can do there
will always be some people who say I
deny everything we ran into a gentleman
the other day there is no virus it's a
hoax it's just a hoax there's no virus
okay go talk to the four hundred people
families who died yesterday and tell me
it's a hoax but you know some people you
just can't do anything why don't we
release cases of incarcerated people yes
what is the list that we would release
people of infirmities lets them in fact
the people prisoner prison the covered
cases per prison or county or region I
don't know does anyone know who's
working on I know we have that
information I get briefed on it daily
I'll work with them after this in to the
extent that we can release the
information we'll release the
information
who hasn't arrested question good Oh
[Music]
different exercise schools are closed
schools are closed all across the state
period there is no plan to reopen
schools period local school districts I
would not be surprised if you heard some
local school school districts say they
plan to reopen we have 700 school
districts by law they cannot reopen but
some want to so they may say we want to
reopen if they want to reopen they can't
reopen because it violates the plan we
have in place so no
schools will reopen if we make a
decision to reopen schools we then would
need a whole plan on how to reopen a
school with the right public health
standards with disinfecting with all the
precautions which is a major major
undertaking so we're not there yet sir
governor can you explain your faith in
contact tracing as part of this restart
plan that was obviously a big emphasis
early on in New Rochelle and that didn't
exactly prevent the current situation
that we're in the New Rochelle contactor
that's a little bit of a non-sequitur
the contact tracing in New Rochelle
didn't prevent what situation that was a
emphasis of the state early on was to
try to track down who the lawyer had
contact with and find those cases but
then we still have this massive outbreak
that extended far beyond that
well yeah you also saw the cluster go
right
that's what contact tracing does a
contact tracing once the outbreak
happens contact tracing is too late to
stop the initial virus infection but
what contact tracing then does is it
comes in okay you were tested positive
who did you contact these two people
contact those two people who did they
contact these two people okay test test
test test test test find the positive
isolate that is it worked in New
Rochelle we did massive contact tracing
after it broke loose that's how we found
out about it it broke loose it was the
hardest cluster in the nation I mean
this was very early on but then we came
in with heavy contact tracing however
the number of people you need to do
contact tracing is tremendous and no one
has even scoped this out right so the
first question is how many tests can you
do for every test you can do you then
need a contact tracer to come
in and trace those contacts from that
person I'm saying we want to get up to
the hundreds of thousands of tests well
if you're doing hundreds of thousands of
tests how many contact tracers do you
need and nobody has near this capacity
logistical management operational so
that has to all be started and then you
have to isolate those people we've been
doing isolation we're good on isolation
as good as you can be but it is all of
this is a place where no one has gone
before it's management intensive
operational intensive it's also cost
intensive which takes us back to cost
who didn't ask a question randomly
hence random selection so if New York
City is 60% of the population then New
York City 60% follows this percent and
it's a statistical model and then
literally random so you just have to
find a way to be on the street corner or
whatever actually get random people
[Music]
yes clearly people are still allowed to
come back in look you should pass the
nursing home we are doing will there be
more tests available there will be more
the question is how how fast can you win